all right so I realized here's the board
is kind of a tough act to follow so I
brought some props that I think will
will help supply things up a little bit
so Harrison Ford writes lightsabers are
cool you guys ever seen a champagne
saber show of hands how many people have
seen a bottle of champagne say bird okay
so here's what I promise you stay till
the end stay awake and I am going to
saber a bottle of champagne for you
it's actually woven into my talk one of
the things I'll talk about is how
important rituals are to get you through
both the high points and the low points
of startup life and sabering champagne
is a ritual that we had at tell apart we
did it sort of around every major moment
whether it was a new customer win or you
know the hiring of a fantastic new
employee the signing of the acquisition
by Twitter we always savored a bottle of
champagne so I wanted to be able to
share that with you in in preparing for
this talk I sort of I realized like how
special this moment is for me and I went
back through some old files and things
and I dug out a couple of things that
that are particularly meaningful that
I'll share with you one is that it was
21 years ago tomorrow that I applied to
get into Stanford and I know that
because I found a letter that I wrote to
the Dean of Admissions dated March 1st
97 which implored him to consider me a
second time for admission to Stanford so
I actually got into Stanford as a as a
freshman straight out of high school but
couldn't afford it so I came from
relatively humble upbringing I mean I
had like incredibly smart hard-working
parents I grew up in a small town in
Wyoming my dad was a coal miner my mom
worked at a community college before
that they ran a small carpet store in
our town and when I got into Stanford
which was really the product of a lot of
good advice that I've had for
from my family of my grandparents I
realized too late that I couldn't
actually afford it so I wrote Stanford a
letter and said hey I can't afford it
but I'll be back and I went to the
University of Wyoming for two years I
worked I saved money and then I
reapplied and so I actually came into
Stanford as a junior transfer in the
fall of 97 so this is actually a really
special moment for me and I remember
when I was trying to make the when I was
making the decision when I got back into
Stanford it was the summer of 97 and the
deadline was coming up for deciding
whether or not I was going to leave
University whelming moved to Stanford
and I was making my pro and con list and
it was a difficult decision because it
sort of built my base with all of my
friends and everything and the
professors that I knew it at Wyoming and
I had to throw all that way to come out
here I'd never been to the campus I
didn't know a single person out here and
I picked up a copy of Fortune magazine
and in that magazine was a two-page
Arial spread of Stanford and it just
talked about like this rich ecosystem of
what was happening in technology and
startups in Silicon Valley at the time
and honestly like I saw it as a sign I
was like okay this is it it's time to
kind of up level my my life my
challenges and in this in this article
there was another interesting picture so
this is Tom Byers and his crew of
students here and they were all part of
this thing called the Stanford
Technology Ventures co-op which now
you'll know as Mayfield Fellows and I
read about this group and I was just
like blown away and I remember thinking
like I want to go to Stanford and I want
to figure out how to be a Mayfield
fellow
another funny little thing you'll see
here on the sides for those listening on
the podcast it talks about this
restaurant in downtown Palo Alto which
is like the deal-making spot right you
think about like Hollywood this is where
all the all the artists get signed and I
have it underlined ill for now had never
heard of a before now I had an underline
because
the time was working in Applebee's and I
thought to myself like that's how I'm
gonna break in I'm going to go be a
waiter at yo Fornaio and I'm gonna
hustle my way into the startup scene
fortunately when I got to Stanford
internships were a plenty and I didn't
have to actually go into foodservice to
make my way into tech but it's pretty
magical that in in really just about two
years time two and a half years time I
went from sort of wide-eyed looking at
this two-page Arial spread of Stanford
magazine or Stanford in Fortune magazine
to a two-page spread of myself in
Stanford magazine I submit this with a
bit of embarrassment quite honestly you
can see yes I did have platinum hair at
the time so did Justin Timberlake just
for the record
but it was my dream come true right like
I became a Mayfield fellow and Stanford
magazine happened to write about the
program and I guess they wanted the
weirdest-looking dude on the cover so
you know so for me like being able to
come here and speak to you all is is
such an amazing feeling but I'm not here
to do a victory lap on my career like
how I got here
I really want to share with you some
like really intense moments of startup
life and give you a framework by which
you can deal with these intense moments
in your own lives especially those of
you that go on to start startups so
briefly my career so as a Mayfield
fellow I then joined an an early stage
company that one of my fellow fellows
worked at called zap late' and I was
there for about three and a half years
that company was a colossal crash and
burn sort of dot-com poster child raised
too much money had no idea what we were
doing and in the summer of 2003 I joined
Google and that was really exciting
because there's a little less than a
thousand people and it felt
very much like a start-up to me like I'd
always wanted to be in and around
startups in the sort of fast-paced
environment and Google although it was
larger really continue to feel like that
for several years so as a Google from
2003 to 2008 I left Google with one of
my tech leads and the two of us became
co-founders we joined Greylock partners
as entrepreneurs and residents built the
company incubated the company inside ran
it independently for the better part of
seven or eight years and then in 2015
twitter acquired us for a little over
half a billion dollars so we we had
grown the company to over a hundred
people well over a hundred million
dollars in revenue and it was a really
exciting moment for us and then for the
two years that followed I became vice
president product Twitter and then I am
now a general partner at Greylock so
it's kind of a fun full circle for me
from the firm that sponsored me as II I
are all the way to an actual investing
partner yet at Greylock so briefly
that's my story and it probably sounds
pretty good like sitting there right
like it's just all up and to the right
we of course know that's not the case
and I've been dealt like a couple of
setbacks in the last year and I was
speaking with a group of fellow CEOs
honestly actually in a program that I'm
a part of called YPO young presidents
organization and to get to know each
other we do this thing called a lifeline
and it's very simple you graph out from
your earliest memory to present day
everything that happened in your life
the high and the low points and there's
the the y-axis is simple it's like on
the top life was great and on the bottom
life with us was lousy and you graph all
of these things out from you know when
you were a kid to to your present day
and the thing that struck me is as I
looked at everybody's graphs of what's
called these life lines is they all
stayed within like a fairly narrow band
and yet to take a step back you're like
well wait a minute like your life has
actually been really up into the right I
mean you
from the small town in Wyoming to now
being you know venture capitalists at
one of the most successful firms of all
time like why why isn't this why doesn't
this trajectory look more up into the
right and I was I was thinking about the
frameworks for how we used to to process
this stuff and there's there's this one
which you guys have probably seen right
the difference between expectation
reality how real messy reality is this
one kind of hurts my brain so let's
let's actually just assume success as a
rational function right and they're a
good friend of mine actually just Lee
who was at Google with me and then went
on to run a company called poly board
before she sold it to Yahoo and I had
traded notes over over a meal several
years ago and she was feeling the same
angst that I was even though both of our
companies were doing well and she
actually came up with this framework
that I've adopted which I really like
which is you know when you think about
success even even something that looks
up into the right obviously you have
highs and lows but what's weird is that
as entrepreneurs when you get to point B
it feels worse than point a right and
you're like well how can that be like B
is clearly better off than a if
successes is on the y-axis and time is
on X like B is just like categorically
better off right and she made this
observation which which I love which is
that we actually feel acutely the rate
of change more than the absolute value
at any one point in time and this is a
very human thing which is think about
you know when you're flying in a plane
you can't really tell if you're going
300 or 400 miles an hour
you can tell however when you're
accelerating and decelerating you can
also tell you know it's really hard to
tell whether you're at 30,000 feet or
35,000 feet but you can really tell when
you hit a pocket of turbulence and you
dropped 50 feet right and so when you
take the first derivative of success you
realize it's actually the rate of change
that you're feeling at any one point in
time so when things are getting better
it feels really great when things are
get
worse it feels really bad regardless of
where you are on that continuum being up
and to the right so I wanted to lay this
out basically as a framework and I'm
going to tell you some stories some of
the accelerating New Times and some of
the decelerating times and the lessons
that I learned from those and hopefully
these will be things that that you guys
can Intuit and apply through your own
journeys cool so the framework that I've
taken is basically thinking about all
the questions that people ask me now as
a successful one-time entrepreneur now
venture capitalist people people come to
you for advice right and I actually
don't like to give advice I just like to
tell stories like to say well this is
what happened to me and if that's useful
this is you know please PLEASE apply
that to your own case so I've taken a
set of questions and then I want to tell
you a set of stories so the first
question how did you know it was the
right time to start a company I'll tell
you a couple things one is don't be in a
rush so much about Silicon Valley I
think insists that we as entrepreneurs
must do things faster must do things
younger whether it's you know Peter teal
and the teal fellows saying I don't even
go to college or it's you know Y
Combinator saying like you know screw
normal jobs just come in and do this
incubator thing the the the sort of
ethos is to go faster and faster and
being younger and younger but it doesn't
have to be that way right if the stars
align for you and that's that's true for
you great but they didn't for me I mean
I was 31 years old when I started my
company and I had been through an
incredible arc of a career that gave me
a really great base of knowledge and
Anna Network right it was frankly that
Network that allowed me to get the offer
of being an entrepreneur in residence
that gave us the sort of backbone that
we needed to build an enterprise
software business so I'd say don't be in
a rush
the second thing I'll tell you is
there's no right time so at Google this
was at the C it's a September 2008 my
co-founder and I had reunited so he was
one of my former tech leads we knew we
liked each other we liked working
together we had ships
really impressive products together and
we both wanted to start a company when
we were both ready the time was right
and so we had worked on some ideas we
had a handful of ideas one of which
became tell apart and we turned in our
resignation at Google and there was just
one little problem which is as you can
see from this chart it was like the
worst time to leave your cushy big
company job this was two weeks before
Lehman Brothers blew up right like
anybody who was kind of plugged into
what was going on was probably
stockpiling like tuna and dog food for
the end of days and we're just like yeah
sounds great like you know forget the
free food and the stock options and
everything let's just like go out on our
own and yeah it's funny like now looking
back I sometimes think what were we
thinking and yet you know the act the
act of entrepreneurship is so difficult
no matter what there is no right time
Reed Hoffman who's one of my partners at
Greylock likens it to jumping off a
cliff and building an airplane on the
way down
Elon Musk says it a little more morosely
where he says starting a company is like
eating glass and staring into the abyss
of death
to the extent that is true and it feels
like that from time to time there's
basically no good time to start a
company but there's also no bad time to
start a company and if you start a
company when the consumer confidence
index is at its lowest point it's been
in decades the nice byproduct of that is
that there's kind of only one way to go
and yes I did Photoshop Drake's head on
an emoji but really like you you you get
steeped and how bad things are and then
things just keep getting better and you
get this tail wind at your back right so
there's no right time and the best the
worst times can also be the best times
the other thing I'll say about how you
know it's the right time is when you can
surround yourself with people who have
yes energy right not yes people not not
people who aren't challenging you but
by-and-large whether it's your
co-founder or in this case James slavit
who is now our managing partner at Grey
and was our sponsor as entrepreneurs and
residents at Greylock he is the kind of
individual who just like they exude this
yes energy right you bring him an idea
and he says yes if or yes and but it
starts with a yes right it's not this
it's not this skeptical like no
cross-arms view of the world it's like
yeah actually I think I think I believe
in you guys like you're smart you're
from Google you can probably figure it
out once you come in and like use one of
our offices here at Greylock for you
know for a few months and until you get
your feet under you just that yes energy
is really empowering isn't as an
entrepreneur so I implore you encourage
you to seek it out and then I'll offer
you this statement that is proven very
valuable for me over the past year which
is simply everything you want is on the
other side of fear so there will be a
point at which the stars are aligning
you found your co-founder you have the
idea maybe you've been offered some seed
money or an entrepreneur in residence
positions something you know the
universe is conspiring with you and then
you will be gripped by fear because
you're about to jump off the cliff right
in a proverbial sense and I just I
really really believe that when at that
moment you can just like say this mantra
everything you want is on the other side
of fear how do we get what we want let's
get on the other side of here let's just
go for it so again to reiterate don't
rush it don't be in a rush you got
plenty of time if technology and the
singularity proves out like we're all
going to live as long as we want upload
our brains to the cloud there's plenty
of time to to decide when starting a
company is right for you there's no
right time the worst time can be as good
as as the best time the yes energy part
surrounding yourself that is really
important and then finally just get on
the other side of that fear next
question how did you know when and how
much money to raise this is a tricky one
but I'll tell you now as a venture
capitalist there is one thing that
matter
when I see entrepreneurs pitch me at any
point in time and that's momentum you
need momentum of the business momentum
of the team momentum of the idea and
then ideally momentum of various venture
capitalists like me starting to get FOMO
to get into your deal right but this
idea of momentum is really important and
so once we once we started out with our
idea we had to build momentum this is a
picture of me on a twin bed in Holiday
Inn in Omaha Nebraska which is where our
first customer was and this was taken
about 3:00 a.m. by my co-founder as you
can see he's sitting on his bed because
we were bunking to save money and our
members like minus 10 degrees out in
February in Omaha Nebraska and we were
so hungry to get our first big win that
we would do anything and once we got
this company to sign with us and say
like yes if you build this software we
will will be your first customer we'll
buy it we went for our funding and so
this is a picture of us signing our
series a term sheet from grain lock
there's James again you can see in the
middle and this was a really exciting
moment for us because everything kind of
came together right it was like it was
suddenly real I have a lot of friends in
industry who say fundraising is not
something to celebrate right they say
like what you haven't done anything like
whoop-dee-doo you got somebody to write
you a check like that's no big deal like
now the hard work begins and that is
true but I also believe that you should
celebrate so so we did we sent out a
silly photo and we we were excited about
it and and we got to work the Brinks
truck did not actually show up by the
way that's that's all Photoshop and so
as we got to work we prided ourselves in
our scrappiness so the first thing that
we did is basically ask Greylock if we
could use some of their extra space and
their extra space was in their old
office and it had kind of this this
hallway that nobody was using with a
bunch of empty rooms on it so we
actually just like set up desks in the
hallway so this is a
Sanjay who's one of our first employees
sitting in the hallway and and we we did
that for about about nine months
actually we incubated and part of that
was because it was like really nice to
like save money and the other part is we
were waiting on an office to open up
that was shared or that was leased by
another Greylock company called cloud
era and so when that opened up I thought
what could be more scrappy than moving
ourselves so we piled all of our stuff
into boxes rented our own u-haul and and
moved it in and it was fun that was kind
of like a fun team bonding moment
although when I look back if the thing
about the lost productivity there's
probably the most expensive move in the
history of man
and then finally down here in the the
lower right corner you can see a picture
of our lobby and you'll notice that
everything that we did in the pictures
that you'll see like it shows really
well it's beautiful
and yet everything that you look at was
either left by the previous tenant or
purchased from Ikea including these
high-gloss white panels that that we
actually put up ourselves and the the
ethos of scrappiness actually ran deep
in our veins and and it was it was it
was useful up until a point and then I
remember I went in to give an update to
the Greylock partnership about 18 months
in and man everything was was going
really well I think we're at a two
million dollar run rate maybe and there
were only four of us and we hadn't spent
very much money who still had most of
the money in the bank and so I go and I
give this I just nailed a presentation
right I'm like look at how great things
are for the low low price of like having
spent almost none of your money and
aren't we awesome and I swear like you
could have heard a pin drop in the gray
light partner meeting I'm like loss is
weird and then one of the partners
Anil Boucherie who's a very very
successful venture capitalist and CEO is
CEO of workday now and has started
multiple companies while being a venture
capitalists multiple billion
companies while being a venture
capitalist he raises his hand he's a
super nice guy and a paraphrase but he
was kind of he kind of said something
like what the hell are you doing
and I'm like what do you mean like this
is awesome isn't it isn't this great
and he's like yeah it's awesome like
clearly you have something here like you
have customers paying you millions of
dollars for software and there's only
four of you and you have no sales people
like what are you thinking like go go go
and the conversation that came out of
that is you guys should raise more money
I'm like oh that's weird like we still
have all the money and there were two
reasons that we actually did raise more
money at that point in time one is
because it was unclear whether or not we
were going to go into a double-dip
recession because this is right when
Greece was was looking like it was going
to blow up and the second was because we
could like in a very short process we
could go out and add another rock star
board member to our board and put a
bunch more money in the bank and then we
could use that to power the business
right so we could almost like get the
capital worries behind us so that we
could just really lean into the end of
the challenge so we did and I took
another picture this is the gentleman
second to the right is a geographer and
he was our second board member
he's from Bain Capital Ventures and he
let our series be a thirteen million
dollar series B and that is a metal
briefcase full of cash
not all 13 million dollars but you know
I think about two things in in the
context of these fun moments and the
startups life
one is I implore you I give you
permission to be a tourist like you feel
kind of silly taking all these photos of
these of these like otherwise mundane
moments in your startups life and then
you realize like how important those are
to the culture that you build and the
stories they get to tell and the other
thing I'll say is you only get one go at
this so you might as well like do some
fun crazy stuff like get a metal brief
put a bunch of cash in it so what did we
do with all of this money well we
figured out how to deploy it in really
high leverage ways for things that
really matter to our business including
giving out cash so we hiring was really
really important for us obviously it is
a friend a startup and it's also really
really hard and you we built a great
culture around hiring and around
referrals and bringing in you know
basically I would say 60% of the company
was probably hired by somebody who
referred to us by somebody who worked
there but we also incentivized it so we
would give a $5,000 cash bonus to
anybody who made the introduction talk
to the candidate into applying with us
and then that person actually became a
tell apartment and the twist was we gave
it out in cash and every time was a
little bit different and every time is a
little more creative and cool the first
one was the proverbial beep briefcase
full of cash I called up Wells Fargo I
said I need a five thousand one dollar
bills they said that's gonna take a
little while we have to order it from us
from the Fed I was like okay and then I
was like and then do I just show up and
do you have a bag and they're like nope
it's BYOB so I showed up with a duffel
bag and went to the teller window and
she went to the back and got a big brick
of cash and stuffed it in the bag and I
walked out in downtown San Francisco
with five grand in a duffel bag which I
proceeded to put into the briefcase if
you look closely you'll also see there's
handcuffs attached to the briefcase and
then at our All Hands we surprised Stan
here who's like an incredibly sweet
young engineer at the time never would
ever deign to ask for a briefcase full
of cash and I'll pull it out from under
the table and I slap it on his wrist and
I say all right open it up and it was it
was just like one of those like really
fun moments for the company the second
one we did was here this woman named
Cindy I asked her sort of offhandedly I
said hey do you like Burberry like I was
thinking about you know buying something
at Burberry is that a good brand is
she's like oh my god I love Burt
so I bought her of Burberry umbrella and
then we dif tada - her and then we
dumped $5,000 in cash on her and then
and then the upper right corner here
you'll see there's basically five
solitaire pendant these are one care one
carat solitaire pendants and underneath
and the displaced and there's a bunch of
other diamonds and and accoutrement and
this was our booth at an e-commerce
conference and we came up with this idea
so the name of the company I guess I
should tell you what we did we built
software that would basically take in
all of his data from retailers all their
transactional data their web data the
mobile traffic data their app data and
then we would build machine learning or
artificial intelligence models to help
them tell apart their high-value
customers from the rest and so when it
came time to get our own booth like here
we are this tiny little company like
nobody cares about us nobody's even
heard about us we said what if we had a
contest with five one carat solitaire
penance four of which we cubic zirconia
one is a real diamond
can you tell apart the real diamond from
the fakes which was fun and it turns out
everybody likes sparkly stuff so we had
this endless stream of traffic at our
booth because you would walk by and
there would just be like all these
glittery like diamonds everywhere and
then we had a jeweler's loupe and you
could go stone by stone and try and pick
it out if you won you got entered into
the contest to actually win the
solitaire and if you lost you've got a
Starbucks gift card and we gave you a
handful of cubic zirconia which turned
out are really cheap and also very
sparkly and fun but it's little things
like this that help push a startup
forward by way of using your cash in a
very smart way and so I'll offer you
these first is it took me a while to get
to really like Intuit this this
statement the way to build value is to
make money not to save money so you can
totally go overboard in the like look
how scrap
we are DIY you know did this all
ourselves and it will be a detriment to
your company like I did not there were a
lot of ways in which I used my time
which were not effective in in
retrospect and so putting yourself into
that mindset of like we're here to build
value through making money was was
really important to accelerating our
success now it's okay to use capital as
a weapon by the way a lot of times
people are sheepish around like how much
money have you raised and now it seems
like you're being profligate with their
spending but if you spend in really
smart ways you can deploy this capital
to beat your competitors to get to
market faster to claim more market
dominance than you would if you were if
you were not spending as aggressively
and then finally hire missionaries like
I would I would tell you every single
person that worked at teleport was not
there for the money but when they did
things that mattered for the company I
tried to reward them like mercenaries
hire missionaries reward like
mercenaries we had a couple of folks who
figured out a change to our software
that basically made us 20% more revenue
overnight and I think we were on a
twenty thirty million dollar run rate I
mean it was like serious rate of change
for our business and so the two people
that worked the hardest on it one of
them I sent to Vegas and with a bunch of
friends on first-class airfare and got
him a table at one of the big nightclubs
there because he loves EDM music and the
other one I sent he and his wife to
Paris also first-class and it's just
like their over-the-top gifts they're
silly it's it's they would you know the
employees would never expect it they
would never deign to even ask for it and
yet having missionaries rewarding them
like mercenaries just really adds to the
momentum of what you're creating another
question how did you assemble such a
great leadership team so this is a
picture of teleport team tell apart we
were probably three years old three and
a half years old at this point and
this is uh you're looking at all this
imagery actually let me get let me give
you the UH this is a cheesy dad joke
stay with me the phrase I always used
when I presented this slide was and we
did this with customers we're team tell
apart and we're outstanding in our field
all right good good thank you thank you
thank you everyone who's laughing right
now thank you so the the logo is a
stylized wheat stock and we talked about
separating the digital wheat from the
chaff again like these things really
make sense when you're from a small town
in Wyoming but you'll notice if you were
to if you were to look closely across
everybody in the company we're missing
one thing
executives we had no executives it was
just my co-founder and I and everybody
that reported to us again almost like
the the scrappiness or the DIY we had
really prided ourselves in how much we
were able to accomplish with nobody
having any title whatsoever you know at
Google I was at Google early and Google
was really a company that eschewed
titles like we didn't give titles to
anyone and and so I the two of us kind
of brought that ethos with us and the
truth is like we overdid it like we
could have gone faster by hiring more
leaders earlier in the company problem
is is really freaking hard and none of
us get very good at it right because um
you don't get to practice hiring VP's
very often in your career and the
problem with executives is that they are
expected to perform at such a level you
don't really have the same kind of like
compassion and caretaking for them that
you do have an individual contributor
and so there's a far shorter timeframe
in which you decide that they work or
don't work and then you're back to
square one and so we went through this a
couple of times you know I had four
different heads of Revenue I had two
different heads of engineering I had at
least two different heads of marketing
and it was difficult it's difficult and
I don't even feel like I got really
really good at it I feel like I got
pretty proficient at it and by the time
we sold to Twitter we had an amazing
leadership team
and so looking back I was like well what
what was I doing wrong like why did why
did I run through so many executives and
there was an op-ed written by a
philosopher a modern-day philosopher
that I really like his name is Alain de
Botton and it came out in the New York
Times about two years ago and it's
titled why you will marry the wrong
person the article is really thoughtful
that the title is is necessarily
hyperbolic but I would encourage you to
read this actually and apply it to all
different dimensions in your life as it
applies to executives what I would have
what I took from the article is he
basically makes this point everyone is
the wrong person because given a
sufficient amount of time particularly
under stress like in a start-up you will
clash with people right and they will do
things that annoy you and I'm sure I was
doing tons of stuff that was annoying
them and it's really difficult to invest
in the relationship when there's that
much stress and that short of a fuse
when you decide if somebody's going to
work or not at the executive level and
so what I took away from this is two
things from the article he says try and
find the mostly not wrong person right
so the mostly not wrong like this person
is actually like super smart more
charred and like I mostly get along with
them and then he says learn to argue
well and that was something that I
really had to practice with my team is
the ability to argue well with them
something that I got better at over time
again never never would claim to be to
be perfect at that a couple of other
thoughts here when we hired across the
board but especially executives I looked
for a characteristic that I call
confident humility or friend of mine
refers to this as confidence without
arrogance this is really hard to find
when you're hiring executives by the way
you know there's something in in Silicon
Valley where once you become a VP you
could never imagine being anything but a
VP again and you come in and you know
you've got this resume that's like VP VP
that actually doesn't mean a whole lot
right
just because they were a VPN one company
doesn't mean they're gonna be successful
in yours and so being able to really
interview them just like you would
anyone in your company is really
important and finding somebody who can
achieve at a particular level and
maintain the humility to be interviewed
is surprisingly difficult and Wade
chambers who became my vice president of
engineering is now CTO at a Greylock
company called Grand Rounds probably
exemplified this the best when I got to
know him he came by way of reference of
two friends that I really trust and they
were like this guy's hands-down the best
engineering leader we have ever seen I
was like sounds great
I should I should hire him and I went to
meet him and he's like look I'm running
you know hundreds maybe 500 engineers
across dozens of offices I'm a public
company officer but I really like your
little startup of twenty people and so I
said great let's get to know each other
and he was so confident in his skills
but so humble in his approach to me that
he would come after working a full day
at his normal day job he would drive
from Saratoga to Burlingame where we
were right so that's 45 minutes and then
he would hang out with me for a couple
of hours at night when everybody else
had left and we would get on the white
board and we would talk about
engineering processes and he would show
me exactly how he would think about
testing out different designs for us and
so he had this confidence
obviously this resume that spoke volumes
but he also had this humility of saying
like sure okay I'll come up your office
I'll get on the whiteboard right we'll
hammer this out together so confident
humility is something that that really
resonated with me our board members at
every turn applied a lot of tough love
to me so when I would come to them and
I'd be like so yeah the third head of
revenue is not working out they're like
mmm
we need to talk they're like look we're
gonna back you up because we love you
and you're the CEO and we trust what
you're doing the company is doing well
but this is not it this is not a
one-sided issue right like what can you
do to improve
and so finding people that can push on
you along with the alignment of your
executives was really important for me
Jeff Markowitz who is our partner for
recruiting at Greylock he handles all of
the major executive searches across the
Greylock portfolio taught me the lesson
that until you've found a bad one you've
never actually checked references
you haven't sufficiently checked
references so you call and you calling
you call and you network your way
through this is really important with
executives until you find a bad
reference you find a bad reference
because it proves to you that this
person is not perfect which none of us
are and because the bad reference will
tell you something about how they behave
in a certain situation or under duress
or maybe when they were less mature that
will help you understand how they think
and how you can navigate around those
issues going forward and then the final
thing I'll reinforce is learn to argue
well arguing is a skill it's really
really freaking hard especially when
you're a headstrong founder and CEO who
created everything from scratch right so
the ability to hear the other person to
understand their words may not exactly
match their intention or what they're
trying to get across the skill of
arguing is really important in building
a successful executive team all right
this one is kind of fun how do you
choose your battles so here's the truth
you are going to get thrown a bunch of
curveballs and some of them are really
gonna suck and I could tell you so many
stories like when Amazon pulled our
contract with Zappos because they wanted
warrants in our company and I was like
that's not fair like what the hell like
Zappos is our customer just because you
bought Zappos doesn't mean that you get
to like own part of my company and
they're just like well that's how it is
so do you want the deal or not and I
like walked away from that customer so
there were lots of instances in which I
lost and then there's one in which we
won so we were sued by a patent troll or
maybe the technical term is
non-practicing entity this was the
weirdest thing that happened we got in
the mail like the lawsuit like if you
were being sued by this company I'm like
what is going on and basically they had
taken a couple of patents and
incorporated and actually gone public
under the ticker symbol P TNT as a
non-practicing entity and employed two
people the CEO and a lawyer and their
only job was to go out and find
companies to sue and the patent was
basically like a patent on submitting
forms on the web or some nonsense right
like something that you would largely
deem like unpatentable it's so obvious
and I don't know if they just like you
know flipped through a phone book of
startups that had recently gotten funded
and just like you know randomly poked on
us but like they sued us and one of our
early customers and this was really
dicey because these things can go bad
right you can lose a ton of money on
legal fees and then you can lose a ton
of money in the courts and they're all
litigated in these strange places in
Texas and it's it's a weird underbelly
of the technology ecosystem
unfortunately and I talked to about it
with my board and I was like look we
have to fight this because if we don't
it'll establish precedence then they're
gonna go after our custom there are
bigger customers and then we're forever
gonna be paying this tax on our revenue
and the worst thing is that then we're
gonna have fueled this patent trolling
entity and they will have precedents
based on tell apartments customers that
they'll go out and they'll tack all
these other startups like we have to put
an end to this and my board fortunately
again like you know backed me on this
and so we did we fought these guys and
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars
but we basically destroyed their company
so we got to a point where we invalidate
the patent we were gonna win our own
case and that was insufficient I was
like no no like let's invalidate their
patent with the USPTO so we spent some
more money to actually take this all the
way and just and take the patent away
from them and when that as that was
happening one of their their majority
external shareholder wrote this open
letter where he said he said you guys
are in a bad situation like you should
just give your
cashback to investors because like tell
apart is gonna kill you
I said its equivalent to being in the
ninth inning of a baseball game down
five nothing with two outs no one on
base and an O to count at the plate and
when that came out like we printed this
out and handed out copies around the
office and you can see roughly in the in
the timeline of their stock price here
when the patent was invalidated and the
fact that they have essentially like you
know gone down to nothing so all's fair
in love and startups you're gonna be
dealt a bunch of things where you're
just like well this sucks
and that's okay you just have to know
which ones you want to fight and which
ones you're gonna let go a couple words
on culture so much has been said about
culture I just want to offer you a
couple of things one is I think space
really really matters we were very proud
of our office if you want to you can go
and on YouTube find our TechCrunch cribs
episode which was really fun more
champagne being savored and it details
how we took this old auto body shop and
turned it into this sort of like
gleaming tech space in downtown
Burlingame which was really fun but the
best part about it was at the end we
were left with just a really great
office that we were happy to come to
work to every day and happy to have
functions and parties in and and I just
think that's really important so don't
don't lose sight of the importance of
your space the other thing I just want
to offer around culture is involve your
people culture is not off sites that are
master-planned it's not you know
bringing in super nice catered lunch
it's really about involving your people
so a few stories top left this is team
tell apart on a Sunday night the Sunday
before cyber monday cyber monday was the
biggest day for retail therefore the
biggest day for our customers therefore
a really important day for us and how
our revenue was built and so for the
Sunday before we would get everybody in
the office and we would decorate a tree
and we would have a potluck and you know
be blasting Christmas music and we would
be preparing for the next day and it
kind of sucked because you're at work on
a Sunday night
the Sunday after Thanksgiving by the way
but it was really really impactful to
building the fabric that carried us
through lower left is a picture of us
having taken that sledgehammer and
smashed through this wall so we had two
parts of our office and we renovated one
section and then over time we subleased
and renovated the next section all that
was left between the two spaces was this
was this drywall section of the wall so
I put on a Ronald Reagan mask gave the
mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall speech
and everybody got to take a swing with
the sledgehammer and we absolutely
destroyed that wall and all the supports
in it and then we marched through and
had champagne on the other side so it's
like it's little things like this right
there it's like we didn't have to do
that but it was so cool to get all these
pictures of people swinging the
sledgehammer at the wall in their office
and then this one here on the right a
little bit hard to see but yes that is a
two-story hill sledding hill of real
snow in Burlingame California and we had
the good fortune of being a very
profitable company there was a point at
which in my January 2014 board meeting I
walked in I said look I want you to hear
me out on something we're gonna do some
crazy stuff we're gonna double our team
size triple our office space by
companies for cash and throw some
serious parties and I want you to
remember it's all 40% off my board is
kind of looking at me like mm what are
you talking about I said well we're out
of what's called net operating losses so
this year we start paying taxes every
dollar that we don't spend 40% of it 40
cents is going to the federal government
so let's start some parties so once a
year we would do this thing called the
tell apart II and we would invite all of
our friends and family and we would
bring them in and we we would just
celebrate with them over what an
incredible and difficult year we had had
in this particular year we brought a
team up from Hollywood that basically
fed ice blocks through a glorified wood
chipper and turned it into a two-story
real snow sledding hill awesome
so space matters rely on your rituals so
per my opening comments like rituals
really matter they help get you through
the down times and they help make the up
times that much more exciting and then
finally involve your team and their
families like bring their kids bring
their significant others bring their
parents let everybody come to these
functions because it really helps them
be a part of what you of what you're
building alright this is the last story
and then I'll open it up for a couple
questions I've actually never talked
about this in public so I'm kind of
excited to share so I get this question
how did you know it was the right the
right path for you was to be acquired
and the answer is you don't you don't
get a a B test life but you are in
control of your destiny
so as you're building your company at
various junctures this happened with us
you're gonna get offers to be acquired
and you will feel differently about
those offers as they come in at the
various points and so along the way
every time I got one of these sort of
soft offers it was never a formal term
sheet but I always got the hey would you
ever consider joining forces with us and
be like oh you're so kind we think so
highly of you but you know we're doing
so well we love being independent and at
some point you just start to say okay
what are our options going forward and
for us our options were put our heads
down and bill for probably two or three
more years and be a public company or be
open to hearing what people had to say
when when these these kind of overtures
came in and what we looked for was a
platform that would really value what we
had built and put us on a bigger stage
to have more impact in the world and so
it was January in 2015 that this man
Anthony Noto who was then my boss for a
little while he was CFO of Twitter at
the time and he's now CEO of sofa it was
at this point that the conversation
started happening I'll say a couple of
things
Anthony is a big guy
he was a linebacker at West Point and
then went to Ranger School and so when
he makes an offer you think twice we had
a bunch of interest that all came in at
the same time and I hired a advisory
firm or a bank called Allen & Company
you may know them for their big Sun
Valley Conference that they do where
Oprah and Bill Gates and all the heads
of state show up and they also hold a
smaller conference in Arizona which is
more technology oriented and so I went
to this conference and it was a really
fun setting because Allen company is so
good at what they do and they're very
very white-glove about how they help
their companies navigate these kind of
processes but what they did for me is
bring me into an environment where all
of the other bidders all the other
people who are interested in acquiring
tell apart at the same time as Twitter
could see the other conversations
happening right and so the first morning
I I went in and I happened to sit next
to the CFO of one of Twitter's
competitors and we'll name names I
happen to sit next to him because like
I've gotten to know him years prior and
he had become kind of a friend so it was
just like hey I'm gonna sit next to
somebody that I know and we're in
session and as we walk out during the
break and we're going down the hallway
the two of us are walking together
anthony Noto is standing there and I can
see him just like laser locked on me
with his his main competitor you know
the other CFO of the other company and
he just kind of like watches us walk by
and the next night I had come down to
dinner late and they had this beautiful
buffet dinner out on the lawn in Arizona
and everybody else was seated with their
dinner and so I'm the last person in the
buffet line right now dusk has sat and
it's getting kind of dark out and so I'm
going through the buffet line putting my
salad on the plate and all of a sudden
like Anthony Noto is on the other side
of the buffet line I'm like where did he
even come from and he's like looking
down at his plate putting his salad on
there and he's he's basically talking to
me but he doesn't want to signal to
anybody else that he's talking to me
right and so he's putting a salad on his
plate he's talking to me but not making
icon
texts and saying tomorrow you're gonna
go on a hike with Dick Costolo who's the
CEO of Twitter at the time and at the
end of that hike you're gonna get a term
sheet from us like we're very serious
about this and we we really want to make
this happen right and so I'm looking
down at my plate talking and I'm like
I'm so excited you guys have been great
through this whole process like you know
I'm really excited for the hike and he's
like okay great so tomorrow 3:00 p.m.
was like great and he looks up and he
says one more thing if I see you talking
to that other CFO I'm gonna break your
legs and then he like disappears into
the bushes just leaves leaves his tray
and his like salad on the plate and just
like disappears into the bushes it was
the most amazing thing Anthony by the
way is a super nice guy he was like one
of the most loved people at Twitter and
he was really fun to work around but he
definitely has a way about him when he
when he's making an offer so the next
day dick and I went on a hike grabbed a
photo obviously be a tourist and then
right after that this is a little dark
but this is the this is sort of the deal
team this is the technical due diligence
team within my company there were only
about 13 of us who knew that this was
going that this was going down and we
all gathered in my in my VP of
engineering's house and we worked all
weekend to prepare ourselves for the
meetings that happen next week the next
week and we thought everything was going
magically well and we we basically were
high-fiving after the meetings because
everything was great and then I got a
call that call came from Kevin wheel who
spoke here a few weeks ago upper
left-hand corner who is SVP a product
and he is like we need to talk and so we
jumped into a conference room at the
Rosewood I drove down from the city he
drove over from Portola Valley and this
is a picture of us here and then the
other picture is of Adam Bain who is
chief operating officer so there's kind
of a threesome earth three-part deal
team the CFO the CEO oh and then the SVP
of product who are all working on this
deal and the two of them
this is Adam doing his best like I'm
blowing up your deal face say legal has
has looked at your contracts they don't
agree with some of the wording like you
know we're really good this is not good
and I'm like what are you talking about
our contracts were written by one of the
best law firms in Silicon Valley like
all of our customers signed them their
legal teams have been through them so I
can't imagine what what you would have
to to pick about and by the way it's
just contracts like I'm sure we can get
through this and for whatever reason
well Twitter's legal team has a lot of
clout at Twitter and obviously I mean
it's a big company they have a lot to
defend but it's spun us out for about a
month and at one of the points I reached
just a real stalemate and so Adam and I
got on the phone and we just kind of
came to a head and he's like alright
well if you're gonna be like if you're
gonna be so dogmatic about this like I
guess the deal's off
and I said well look like I told my team
to put their pencils down like we're not
working on this anymore until you guys
come back with something more reasonable
and he's like okay we just hung up the
phone and like my heart just sank
because like you know we had worked so
hard to get the deal all the way through
and now I had my team and everybody was
getting spun up on what the future could
look like with our two companies
combined and we really I mean it was
dead it was dead dead dead and then a
couple days later the phone rang and
they said okay we think we found a
clever way around this let's work it out
so as luck would have it everything came
together there's a nice little picture
of our two logos mashed-up which I think
I made myself in Photoshop while being
interminably bored on the phone with
lawyers one night and I wanted to
screenshot this just because it's it's
uh it's pretty special so dick who's the
CEO had texted me and this is like the
deal was clearly gonna go through it's
like the morning that that we were going
to announce and he says how you holding
up did I ever tell you my M&A rule
probably should have told you earlier
castelo's rule of M&A to which I answer
never
go in against a ceiling when death is on
the line The Princess Bride fans okay
he says close every deal dies three
deaths before it closes and that was
really magical for me our deal did not
die our deal went through this is an
this is a picture of us in what I still
maintain is the world's largest
coordinated champagne sabering ever
everybody on the team got us champagne
saber engraved with that deal logo that
you just saw we went up to the roof of
our building we filmed it by drone and I
think it was executed
absolutely expertly only one person was
harmed in the making of the film and it
was just a very minor very minor cut but
this is this was this was really special
and it was really amazing so to
reinforce you're in control of your
destiny think about this think about how
you want to proceed with your company
expect three deaths and believe in in
what's called your Batna your best to
turn the alternative to the negotiated
agreement what made me so confident in
in holding my ground against Twitter is
that we were running a really great
company with really great
characteristics that was very profitable
and we knew we could always go back to
being that so that was that was pretty
magical now I would like to tell you of
course I'd like to have you believe that
everything after the acquisition was up
into the right no surprise it wasn't
even if it was it wouldn't have felt
that way you know we navigated through
two layoffs a lot of change at Twitter
and yet I'm very very proud of what the
team is accomplished
and very bullish on where the company is
going from here two things that I want
to say this is a really rocky road and
you're not the only person going through
it in your life your significant other
to the extent you have one at the time
that you're building your company is
also going to be feeling this very
acutely and don't forget to pitch them
on why things are going to work out
sometimes you bring home all the
negative energy that you can't share
with your team on any given day
a you just kind of dumped it inside your
for safe walls and you should not do
that you should treat your significant
other like you would a board member or
an investor an employee a candidate that
you're pitching like help them believe
why this is going to be successful the
last thing is make no little plans my
favorite architect one of my favorite
architects is named Daniel Burnham he
designed the Flatiron Building in New
York and he has this quote and the
reason I'll leave you of this is it is
as hard to run a company of two people
as it is to run one of 200 of two
million dollars of 200 million dollars
so make no little plans like really
bring the full force of everything that
you have from creativity to passion to
drive to expectations of outcome it will
be worth your time and I wish you guys
all a lot of luck
shall we alright
might want to turn off the camera for
this just in case it goes badly just
kidding
alright so the physics of savoring a
champagne bottle a bottle is actually
two halves that have been melted
together if you look on the bottle you
can see a tiny faint vertical line
that's the weakest point at the neck you
want to take the blade the blade does
all the work it's actually not sharp at
all it's just the weight you want to run
it along the neck and then you want to
connect right with the right with the
the sort of outcropping here and the
bottle is under 90 pounds of pressure
per square inch so that's about double
that of a car tire so the bottle and the
blade do all the work right ready for
this all right can I get like a drumroll
anything there we go all right here we
go team just that easily
[Applause]
pretty memorable student please join me
in giving him a big round of applause
[Applause]
you